so yeah we always ask this to every el
person who now lives in l.a do you enjoy
living in l.a
because i swear every person we've met
just on this trip alone who lives here
is just like yeah so so what's it like
living in l.a and 90 of them are like
it's [ __ ]
but i can't leave i can't say it's [ __ ]
but you do feel a little bit like a
prisoner
sorry not
uh
like how you can feel imprisoned in like
a toxic relationship that's the best way
to put it it's like i just can't chains
of the mind okay but there are major
downsides but there are major upsides so
i can't say it's great like i'm very
loving and i mean prison has upsides as
well you know free food yeah
accommodation you know this is this
there's an upside down yes there's some
things no okay la is really not that bad
obviously or else i wouldn't live there
yeah um
but it really is
it's a toxic relationship that's right
would you ever consider moving out if
you know you you wanted to take some
time off or twitch or whatever she would
i think
for starters i could not possibly
imagine raising a family in los angeles
yeah i don't know how people
do that
i really don't but the weirder parts are
still trying to figure out sex she's
yeah literally they're waiting for
marriage
think about this the next time you guys
are out just think about i guess like
how many kids you see you don't see any
yeah yeah exactly
where do the babies go where do the
babies go
i guess they get shipped off to other
parts of america
qx files theme
i gotta say it is weird
walking past high schools in the middle
of [ __ ] like hollywood yeah and i'm
just seeing like barricades on these
schools like i couldn't imagine going to
a school that looks like a prison
and that's that's why like i'm really
grateful i feel like i grew up
albeit maybe it was a little bit like a
naive way to grow up i think it's good
to be a little more on the sheltered and
i have some naivety still exactly the
moment you go online it's all gone so
why not enjoy it well how long have you
lived in l.a uh about
five years five years okay okay so like
four years in like streamer houses
yeah what's what's what's what's inside
i say this because some of them were
most of them were officially streamer
houses like i lived with otv but then i
lived with streamers but we weren't like
we were a household content creators
like make contact together yeah yeah
yeah and then i decided to live alone
which is enjoying it so far
yeah
yeah yeah because
[Music]
yeah when pokey first came here we were
like apologizing for how messy our house
is which to me
look at our house it's a [ __ ] mess
which it is and she was like no no no
this this is like a clean house and i'm
like we haven't vacuumed in two weeks
because this house for some reason
doesn't have a vacuum so it's it's like
it doesn't have a lot of sleep mess yeah
so when it comes to cleanliness after
being in like content creator houses for
four years my standards are on the
ground
and everything else is on the ground too
can i say that was the most gross thing
you've seen yeah
you don't have to name names
because like i lived there like i'm not
saying i'm the cleanest person i'm
saying it's just messy
um but very much like it's typically
like junk or like food stuff
especially because
you usually don't have designated people
for specific tasks right yeah taking out
the trash yeah yeah because you're old
and then we got those little like zapper
thingies oh yeah
and every now and then you hear a large
zap because it's a fly who's like
and everyone turns around like just
another dead fly yeah because it just
kind of sounds like a frat house right
because i was yeah i was gonna ask do
you do did you have like a cleaning
rotor where you know you take turns
cleaning the house or was it just
whoever was like the most disgusted
first cleaned the house to be fair we
would have cleaners come every maybe
like two weeks
um it's just it's hard to manage that
many people without having someone be
like you do this and you do this you do
that and when you're in a group of
friends like no one really wants to do
that right of course and i i
i think i ended up not being the
cleanest either but i would just try to
be as messy as possible in my room right
right right
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then i get
bothered by myself and i have to clean
up after myself and run right how's your
apartment now then is it is it clean is
it [ __ ] and spam or is it is it the same
the same pokey streamer house i think
it's pretty nice right now i still have
a lot of like moving unpacking well
we'll ask you again in two weeks and see
if the answer is the same yeah if you've
just moved in that doesn't count because
it's always always cleansy yeah insane
and then for me it's like my environment
is a reflection of my brain like if i'm
stressed before a trip everything's
everywhere and i'm gone because i just
like spent the last five hours packing
yeah oh no but like the worst feeling is
when you come back you're [ __ ]
exhausted from the flight you've you've
had a great time and you come back and
the house is a [ __ ] mess
get a cleaner while you're gone
see money you come home and you're like
i live here it feels very like blobby
like your mom cleaned you know honestly
that's like
wow family no it's just a cleaner you
paid like a hundred dollars to clean
honestly that's that's what i love
saying about in like about staying about
in hotels you know you go out
you go out
the room's a [ __ ] mess and you're
like i know it's gonna be clean when
they come when i come back
yeah i know it's gonna be [ __ ] and spam
and i can have a good night's sleep so
yeah
so you've obviously um like moving on
now from like to like the twitch stuff
right because it's like how long have
you been doing twitch now i i feel like
you've been on the platform forever like
nine years geez
eight to nine years somewhere in between
there my god that's insane you're still
enjoying it obviously
or is that a loaded question
yeah
obviously generally net positive right
youtube you know yeah yeah it's just
like youtube but you've seen the
platform change so much like it's
completely different because like
obviously i haven't been doing it as
long as you but like even just in the
short amount of time i've been doing
twitch it's like changed [ __ ]
dramatically right not just the platform
but the audience
right
it becomes like more diversified with
every year which i
can't say enough how much i appreciate
yeah right i mean like with in terms of
the countries or just in general
interests and everything like that in
general interests gender espec
especially
uh countries a little bit but i feel
like it kind of grows
everywhere all at once right right yeah
because i guess when you started
was it mostly males that were on twitch
you played league right yeah so that's
just oh i'm sorry
thank you yeah
my condolences
we both played a lot of league
yeah we both played a long league so we
get it as well yeah oh yeah yeah do you
guys remember like back in the day
especially when league was always like
the most popular on twitch
what was like running rampant was these
videos talking about like
female twitch streamers and cleavage
like that was the thing yeah that was
the click bait everywhere and it was
like
almost like this propaganda that spread
across and i was like this is where you
find
you know
hot single ladies in your area
all single league plays in your area
they don't exist
twitch was so new that was like the
first thing to like virally
circulate about female streamers oh my
god she wore this oh my god she did that
she was donated this much and it's just
been like
so many years and so much work to kind
of move past that and be like yeah
there's women of all types just like in
real life yeah right who knew yeah
what a shock